le sénateur avec Boquet vous l'avez dit
Gabriel Attal est retenu avec Bruno Le
Maire l'Assemblée nationale pour un
débat d'orientation des finances
publiques il m'a donc chargé de vous
répondre non pas sur l'aire de l'Hymne à
l'amour je ne l'île talent ni la voix
d'Édith Piaf mais pour commencer par
vous remercier quand même en mon nom
mais surtout en son nom pour le travail
que vous avez fait sur ce sujet depuis
longtemps vous aviez mené une mission
d'information je pense même que c'est
une commission d'enquête au Sénat en
2012 vous avez participé à toutes les
réunions du groupe de travail qu'à
monter Gabriel Attal en ce début d'année
je pense que vous avez été aussi un
membre extrêmement actif de la
commission d'enquête du Sénat qui durant
l'année 2022 a fait les travaux et oui
ces travaux nous ont inspirés notamment
sur ce que vous appelez la COP fiscale
qui va permettre de parfaire les
relations et le travail de coopération
au niveau international pour traquer la
fraude fiscale là où elle est vous le
savez je pense depuis six ans le
gouvernement a fait des choses sur ce
sujet si les multinationales sont
désormais taxées à un niveau minimal
dans le monde c'est grâce au
gouvernement français c'est grâce à la
détermination de son tout simplement
d'un autre gouvernement qui a porté ce
sujet au niveau international et nous
allons continuer à le faire dans le
cadre de cette COP fiscale par ailleurs
nous allons vous le savez renforcer les
moyens domestiques pour traquer la
fraude fiscale avec 1500 agents
supplémentaires d'ici la fin du
quinquennat on va avoir aussi des moyens
nouveaux modernes de traquer les flux et
de traquer y compris les flux des
personnes pour s'assurer que celles et
ceux qui ne sont pas en France en tout
cas légalement ne réside pas en France
on y passe pas trop de temps et on va
par ailleurs évidemment vous le savez
aussi travailler sur la symétrie des
relations entre l'administration et les
contribuables quand un contribuable
commet une erreur il paye des intérêts
de retard il est important que
l'administration en face d'eux-mêmes
vis-à-vis de contribuables qui auraient
eux-mêmes souffert d'une erreur vous
voyez nous ne mégotons pas sur les
moyens à la fois domestique à
l'international et nous continuons cette
lutte contre l'optimisation fiscale
voire même la fraude fiscale sur
laquelle nous souhaitons augmenter les
moyens et nous allons le faire merci
[Musique]